the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
the topic for today is going to be
equations of planes and how it relates
how they relate to linear systems and
made faces as we have seen during
Tuesday's lecture so let's start again
with equations of planes so remember
we've seen briefly that an equation our
plane is of the form ax plus B y plus cz
equals d where a b c and d are just
numbers okay and so this expresses the
condition for a point at coordinates XYZ
to be in the plane and so an equation of
this form defines a plane so let's see
how that works again so let's start with
an example let's say that we want to
find an equation for the plane for the
origin with normal vector
let's say vector n equals let's say the
normal vector 1 5 10 okay so how do we
find an equation of this plane well
remember that
we can get that equation by thinking
geometrically so what's our thinking
going to be well we have the XYZ axes
and we have this vector n 1 5 10 and
it's supposed to be perpendicular to our
plane and our plane passes for the
origin here okay so we want to think of
the plane that's perpendicular to this
vector well when is a point in that
plane let's say we have a point P I'll
call it X Y Z well the condition for P
to be in the plane should be that we
have a right angle here so P is in the
plane
whenever opie dot n is 0 and if we write
that explicitly well vector o P has
components X Y Z and has components 1 5
10 so that will give us X plus 5 y plus
10 Z equals 0 that's the equation of our
plane
now let's think about a slightly
different problem so let's do another
problem let's try to find the equation
of a plane for a point p0 with
coordinates say - 1 - 1 and with normal
vector again the same guy 1 5 10 so how
do we find an equation of this thing
well we are going to use the same method
in fact let's think first for a second
so I said we have a normal vector n and
it's going to be perpendicular to both
planes at the same time so in fact our
two planes will be parallel to each
other the difference is well before we
had a plane that was perpendicular to n
and passing for the origin and now we
have a new plane that's going to pass
well not for the origin but for maybe
this point p0 and I don't really know
where it is but let's say for example
that p0 is here then I will just have to
shift my plane so that instead of
passing for the origin it passes for
this new point ok
so how we're going to do that well now
for point P to be in our new plane we
need four vector no longer o P but P
Zero P to be perpendicular to n okay so
P is in this new plane if the vector p 0
P is perpendicular to N and now let's
think for a second what's vector p 0 P
well we take the coordinates of P and we
subtract those of p 0 so that should be
X minus 2 y minus 1 and Z plus 1 dot
product with 1 5 10 equals 0 let's
expand this well we get X minus 2 plus 5
times y minus 1 plus 10 times Z plus 1
equals 0
let's put the constants on the other
side we get X plus 5 y plus 10 Z equals
well here we have minus 2 becomes 2
minus 5 becomes 5 10 becomes minus 10 I
think we end up with negative 3 so see
the only thing that changes between
these two equations is the constant term
on the right-hand side the thing that I
call D and the other common feature is
that the coefficients of x y&z 1 5 and
10 correspond exactly to the normal
vector okay so that's something you
should remember about planes these
coefficients here correspond exactly to
a normal vector and well this constant
term here roughly measures how far you
know when you move from so if you have a
plane through the origin the right-hand
side will be 0 and if you move to a
parallel plane then this number will
become something else
so how actually could we have found that
- way more quickly well we know that the
first part of the equation is like this
ok and we know something else we know
that the point p 0 is in the plane so if
we plug the coordinates of p 0 into this
well X is 2 plus 5 times 1 plus 10 times
minus 1 we get minus 3 so in fact the
number we should have here should be
minus 3 so that p 0 is a solution ok so
let me point out so maybe I'll put a 1
here again so this way numbers 1 5 10
are exactly the normal vector
and one way that we can get this number
here is by computing the value of the
left hand side at the point p 0 we plug
in the point p 0 into the left hand side
okay
any questions about that no okay by the
way I mean of course a plane doesn't
have just one equation it has infinitely
many equations because if I take instead
say if I multiply everything by 2 2x +
10 y plus 20 is equals minus 6 is also
an equation for this plane okay
that's because of course we have normal
vectors of all sizes we can choose how
big we make it so again just to repeat
the single most important thing here in
the equation ax plus B y plus is equals
D the coefficients ABC give us actually
a normal vector to the plane so that's
why in fact what matters to us mostly is
finding the normal vector and in
particular if you remember last time I
explained something about how we can
find normal vector to the plane if we
know point in the plane namely we can
take the cross product of two vectors
contained in the plane
okay so let's just do an example to see
if we completely understand what's going
on so let's say that I give you the
vector with components 1 2 negative 1
and I'll give you the plane X plus y
plus 3z equals 5 so do you think this do
you think that this vector is parallel
to the plane perpendicular to it neither
okay I'm starting to see a few votes
okay so
I see that most of you are answering
number two this vector is perpendicular
to the plane there are some other
answers too well let's try to figure it
out okay so let's do the example say V
is 1 2 negative 1 and the plane is X
plus y plus VZ equals 5 so let's just go
you know that plane anywhere it doesn't
really matter let's first get a normal
vector out of it well to get a normal
vector to the plane what I will do is I
will take the coefficients of x y&z so
that's 1 1 3 okay so 1 1 3 is
perpendicular to the plane how do we get
all the other vectors that perpendicular
to the plane that are perpendicular to
the plane well all the perpendicular
vectors are parallel to each other okay
so that means that they are just
obtained by maybe multiplying this guy
by some number ok 2 to 6 for example
would still be perpendicular to the
plane 1/2 1/2 square halves is also
perpendicular to the plane but now see
these guys are not personal to each
other so V is not perpendicular to the
plane
so it's not perpendicular to the plane
being perpendicular to the plane is the
same as being parallel to its normal
vector
now what about testing if V is instead
parallel to the plane
well it's parallel to the plane if it's
perpendicular to n well let's check that
so let's try to see if it's
perpendicular to n well let's do V dot n
that's 1 2 negative 1 dot 1 1 3 you get
1 plus 2 minus 3 let's 0 so yes so if
it's perpendicular to n means
maybe it's somewhere like that it's
actually going to be parallel to the
plane okay any questions yes ah when you
plug let's see so if I plug the vector
into the plane equation so x1 plus 2
minus 3
well the left-hand side becomes 0 so
it's not a solution of a plane equation
ok so I should say ok so there's two
different things here one is the point
with coordinates 1 2 minus 1 is not in
the plane ok so what that tells us is
that if I put my vector V at the origin
okay then the point here is not going to
be in the plane on the other hand you're
right the left-hand side evaluates to 0
what that means is if instead I had
taken the plane X plus y plus 3z equals
0 then it would be inside and the plane
X plus y so this one is X plus y plus 3z
equals 5 X plus y plus 3z equals 0 would
be a plane parallel to it but for the
origin so that would be another way to
see that the vector is parallel to the
plane if we move a plane to a parallel
plane for the origin then the end point
of the vector is in the plane ok that's
another way to convince yourselves
any other questions
okay so let's move on so last time we
saw about matrices we learnt about
matrices and linear systems so let's try
to think now about linear systems in
terms of equations of planes and
intersections of planes I mean remember
a linear system it's a bunch of
equations let's say a 3x3 linear system
it's three different equations each of
the equation is the equation of a plane
so in fact if we try to solve a system
of equations that means actually we're
trying to find a point that is in
several planes at the same time so one
more world here
so let's say that we have a 3x3 linear
system and just to take an example
doesn't really matter what I give you
but let's say I give you X plus Z equals
1 X plus y equals 2x plus 2y plus a Z
equals 3 well what does it what does
this mean
what does it mean to solve this it means
we want to find X Y Z which satisfy all
these conditions so let's just look at
the first equation first
well first equation says our point
should be on the plane which has this
equation then the second equation says
oh our point should also be on this
plane okay so in fact if you just look
at the first two equations that means
you have two planes and the solutions
so these two equations determine for you
two planes and two planes intersect in a
line okay now well what happens with a
third equation that's actually going to
be a third plane so if we want to solve
the first two equations we have to be on
this line and if we want to solve the
third one we also need to be on another
plane and in general three planes
intersect in a point because this line
of intersection so
okay so where planes intersect in a
point and one way to think about it is
that the line where the first two points
so I've aligned with where the first two
planes intersect meets the third plane
in a point and that point is the
solution to the linear system okay so
the line let's say form by V so this is
mathematical notation for the
intersection between the first two
planes intersects the third plane in a
point which is going to be the solution
okay
so the solution actually how do we find
it well one way is to draw vectors and
try to figure out where the solution is
but that's not how we do it in practice
if we are given the equations the
solution is given sorry so let me use
matrix notation remember we saw on
Tuesday that the solution to ax equals B
is given by x equals a inverse B and we
get from here to here by multiplying on
the left by a inverse inverse a X
simplifies to x equals a inverse B and
once again it's n must be and not be a
inverse if you try to set up the
multiplication be a inverse doesn't work
the sizes are not compatible you can't
multiply the other way around
okay so that's pretty good unless well
unless it doesn't work that way okay
and what could go wrong well let's say
that our first two planes do intersect
nice clean line but let's think about
the third plane maybe the third plane
does not intersect that line nicely no
point
maybe it's actually parallel to that
line okay so let's try to think about
this question for second oh sorry
so let's say that the set of solutions
to a three by a linear system is not
just one point so we don't have a unique
solution that we can get this way what
could happen what do you think would
happen
okay I see answers number three and five
seem to be done in ating there's also a
bit of answer number one and in fact
these are pretty good answers I see when
some of you figured out that you can
answer one and three at the same time
okay and five at the same time i yet
have to see somebody with five hands and
so all three numbers at the same time
but okay so indeed will see very soon
that we could have either no solution a
line or plane the other answers well two
points two solutions we will see is not
actually a possibility because if you
have two different solutions when the
entire line for these two points is also
going to be made of solutions a
tetrahedron is just where to you know
amuse you
it's not actually a good answer to that
question it's not very likely that you
will get a tetrahedron out of
intersecting planes a plane isn't it
possible and I don't know is still okay
for a few more minutes but we're going
to get to the bottom of this and then we
will know okay so let's try to figure
out what can happen so let me go back to
my picture and so I had my first two
planes the datum in a line and now I
have my third plane and maybe my third
plane is actually parallel to the line
but doesn't pass for it well then I'm
afraid that there's no solutions okay
because to solve the system of equations
I need to be in the first two planes so
that means I need to be in that vertical
line well the kind was supposed to be
red but I guess it doesn't really show
up as right and it also needs to be in
the third plane but the line on the
planar parallel to each other there's
just no place where they intersect okay
so there's no way to solve all the
equations on the other hand the other
thing that could happen is that actually
the line
is contained in the plane and then well
it means any point on that line will
actually solve automatically the third
equation okay so if you try solving a
system that looks like this by hand what
you will notice you know if you do
substitutions eliminations and so on
what you will notice is that you know
after you've dealt with two of the
equations the third one here would
actually turn out to be the same as what
you got out of the first two it doesn't
give you any additional information it's
as if you had only two equations the
previous case would be when actually the
third equation contradicts something
that you can get out of the first two
for example maybe out of the first two
you got X plus Z equals one and the
third equation is X plus Z equals two
well it can't be one and two at the same
time maybe another way to say it is that
this picture is one way you can get you
know out of the equations you get a
number equals a different number that's
impossible and that picture is one where
out of the equations you get zero equals
zero which is certainly true but it
isn't very useful equation so you can't
actually finish solving okay so let me
write that down
so unless the third plane say it is
parallel to the line where p1 and p2
intersect so then there's two sub cases
if the line of intersections of p1 and
p2 is actually contained in p3 in the
third plane then we have infinitely many
solutions namely any point on the line
will automatically solve the third
equation
now the other possibility the other sub
case is if the line of intersection of
p1 and p2 is parallel to p3 and not
contained in it then we get no solutions
okay so again just to show you pictures
once again when we have the first two
planes they give us a line and now
depending on what happens to that line
in relation to the third plane various
situations can happen
so if the third line just hits so if a
line hits the third plane in a point
then that's going to be our solution and
if that line instead is parallel to the
third plane well if it's parallel and
outside of it when we have no solution
if it's parallel and contained in it
actually then we have infinitely many
solutions okay so going back to our list
of possibilities that means well let's
see what can happen so no solution well
we've seen that happens when the line
where the first two planes intersect is
parallel to the third one that exists
two points well that didn't come up okay
and as I said the problem is if the line
of intersection of the first two planes
actually has two points that are in the
third plane well then that means
actually the entire line must also be in
the third plane so if you have two
solutions and you have more than two
actually in fact you have infinitely
many and we've seen that can happen ok
tetrahedron still doesn't look very
promising
what about a plane well that's a case
that I didn't explain because I've been
assuming that p1 and p2 are different
planes and they intersect in a line but
in fact well they could be parallel in
which case we already have no solution
to the first two equations or we could
be the same plane and now if a third
plane is also the same plane you know if
all three planes are the same plane well
then you have a plane of solutions you
know if I give you three times the same
equation that is a linear system it's
not a very interesting one but it is a
linear system okay and I don't know is
no longer the solution either okay any
questions yes okay so that's a very good
question the question is whether it's
via metric significance of an equation
like X plus y plus Z or say this one
equals two one two three or something
else well if the equation is X plus y
plus Z equals zero it means that our
plane is passing for the origin and then
if we change the constant it means we
move to a parallel plane so the first
guess that you might have is that this
number on the right hand side is the
distance between the origin and the
plane it tells us how far from the
origin we are that is not quite true in
fact that would be true if the
coefficients here form the unit vector
then this guy would just be the distance
to the origin otherwise you have to
actually scale by the length of this
normal vector and I think there's a
problem in the notes that will show you
exactly how this works okay but you
should think of it hopefully as how much
have we moved the plane away from the
origin that's the meaning of this last
term d that's in the right hand side of
the equation
okay
so let's try to think about what exactly
this case you know how do we detect now
in which situation we are because that's
all very nice in the picture but you
know it's difficult to the whole planes
in fact when I draw these pictures I'm
always very careful not to actually try
to pretend to draw an actual plane given
by an equation when I do when it's
blatantly false it's difficult to the
whole plane correctly so instead let's
try to think about it in terms of
matrices in particular what's wrong with
this you know why can't we always say
the solution is x equals a inverse B
well so the point is actually you cannot
always invert the matrix okay so recall
we've seen this formula that a inverse
is one of our determinant of a time's
the adjoint matrix and well we've
learned how to compute this thing
remember we had to take minus then flip
some signs and then transpose well
that's that we can always do we can
always do these calculations but when at
the end we have to divide by the
determinant well let's find if the
determinant is not 0 but if the
determinant is 0 then certainly we
cannot do that so in fact what I didn't
mention last time is that the matrix is
invertible that means it has an inverse
exactly when it's determinant is not 0
okay so that's something we should
remember
so if a determinant is not zero then we
can use a method to find the inverse and
then we can solve using this method if
not when not yeah that's correct
so what I'm saying is we can invert a
matrix a if the determinant is not zero
and if you look again at the method that
we saw last time so first we had to
compute this adjoint matrix and these
operations we can always do if we are
given a 3x3 matrix we can always compute
the adjoint and then the last step to
find the inverse was to divide by the
determinant and that we can only do if
the determinant is not 0 so if we have a
matrix whose determinant is not 0 then
we know how to find the inverse if the
determinant is 0 then of course this
method doesn't work but I'm saying
actually even more
there isn't an inverse at all it's not
just that our method fails I cannot take
the inverse of the matrix with
determinant 0 and geometrically well
precisely the situation where the
determinant is not 0 is exactly this
nice usual situation where the three
planes intersect in a point while the
situation where the determinant is 0 is
this situation here where everline
determined by the first two planes is
parallel to the third plane so
let me emphasize this again and let's
see again what happens okay
so let's not leave an easier case so
it's called the case of a homogenous
system it's called homogeneous because
it's the situation where the equations
are invariant under scaling so
homogeneous system is one where the
right-hand side is zero okay there's no
B if you want the constant terms here
are all zero zero zero zero okay so this
one is not homogeneous so let's see what
happens there well so what that means
you know so let's take an example
instead of this guy we could take X plus
Z equals zero X plus y equals zero and X
plus 2y plus AZ also equals zero well
can we solve these equations yeah I
think actually you already know a very
simple solution to these equations yeah
you can just take x y&z all to be zero
so there's always an obvious solution
namely zero zero zero and in
mathematical German this is called the
trivial solution okay so there's always
this trivial solution and what's the
geometric interpretation well having
zeros here means that all three planes
pass for the origin so certainly the
origin is always a solution
the origin is always a solution because
three planes pass over the origin okay
so now there's two sub cases one case is
if the determinant of the matrix a is
nonzero well that means that we can
invert it so if we can invert a then
that means we can solve the system by
multiplying by a inverse we multiply by
a inverse well we get x equals a inverse
times 0 which is 0 okay and that's the
only solution because well you know if
ax is 0 then let's multiply by a inverse
we get a inverse ax that's x equals a
inverse 0 that's 0 we get x equals 0
we've solved it ok no other solution
so to go back to this pictures that we
all enjoy
it's it's this case okay now the other
case if the determinant of a equals zero
then it means that actually this doesn't
quite work so let's see what does it
mean the determinant of a zero well
remember the entries in a they are the
coefficients in the equations okay but
now the coefficients in the equations
they are exactly the normal vectors to
the planes so that's the same thing as
saying by the determinant of the three
normal vectors to our three planes is
zero
so
that means that n1 n2 and n3 are
actually in the same plane
it's called coplanar is a vectors are
coplanar so let's see what happens so I
claim it will correspond to this
situation here let's draw the normal
vectors to these three planes okay well
it's not very easy to see but okay so
I've tried to draw the normal vectors to
my planes well they're all in the
direction that's perpendicular to the
line of intersection they are all in the
same plane so if I try to form a box in
Auto Nelly pipette with this way normal
vectors where I will get something
that's completely flat and has no volume
as volume zero okay so the
parallelepiped has volume zero and the
fact that the normal vectors are
coplanar tells us that in fact let me
start on your blackboard if we okay so
now let's say that our normal vectors n
1 n 2 and 3 are all in the same plane
and let's think about the direction
that's perpendicular to n1 n2 and n3 at
the same time I claim that will be the
line of intersection
so let me try to draw that picture again
so we have three planes
now you see why I put up a picture in
advance it's easier it would beforehand
and I said the normal vectors are all in
the same plane so what else do I know I
know that all these planes pass for the
origin okay so the origin is somewhere
in the intersection of the three planes
now I said actually the normal vectors
to my three planes well it's kind of
hard to hold it our all
actually coplanar okay so N one and two
and three let I'm in a plane well now if
I look at the line for the origin that's
perpendicular to n1 n2 and n3 so
perpendicular to this red plane here
that's a terrible picture it's supposed
to be in all the planes okay you can see
that better on the side screens okay and
why is that well that's because my line
it's perpendicular to the normal vectors
so it's parallel to the planes it's
parallel to all the planes now why is it
in the planes instead of parallel to
them well that's because my line goes
for the origin and the origin is on the
plane
so certainly my line has to be contained
in the planes not parallel to them so
the line for the origin and
perpendicular to the plane of and one
and two and three
is parallel to all fillings and because
the planes go for the origin it's
contained in okay so what happens here
is I have in fact infinitely many
solutions
and how do I find these solutions well
if I want to find something that's
perpendicular to n1 n2 and n3 well if I
just want to be perpendicular to n1 and
n2 I can take their cross product
exactly so
for example if I do n1 plus n2 is
perpendicular to n1 and to n2 and also
to n 3 because n3 is in the same plane
as n1 and n2 so if you are happening it
up to n1 and n2 you're also
perpendicular to n 3 it's automatic so
it's a non-trivial solution this vector
goes along the line of intersections so
that's the case of homogeneous systems
and then let's finish with the other
case so the general case so that means
if we look at a system ax equals B well
with B now anything there's two cases if
the determinant of a is not zero then
there's a unique solution namely x
equals a inverse B if the determinant of
a is zero then it means actually we have
the situation with you know planes that
are all parallel to the same line and
then we have either no solution or
infinitely many solutions it cannot be a
single solution now whether you have no
solutions or infinitely many solutions
well we haven't actually developed the
tools to answer that but if you try
solving the system by hand by
elimination you will see that you end up
maybe with something that says 0 equals
0 and you have Internet
Solutions you know actually if you can
find one solution then you know that
there's infinitely many on the other
hand if you end up with something that's
a contradiction like one equals two then
you know there's no solutions okay so
that's the end for today and tomorrow we
will learn about parametric equations
for lines and curves